happy birthday grandma  my uh my grandmother's name was sybil  carmichael  she died over a decade ago but i still  keep  her birthday in my calendar so that when  it comes up which is today  i think about her and i remember her  just to keep that memory alive she was  one of the nicest people  that you'd ever meet in the world she  always found a way to say  something good about somebody and find  a positive thing out of any negative  situation  and she believed you know it's funny  it's my word but she she really believed  in people and in things and  and she helped teach me to believe so i  love you grandma thinking about you  today  love you miss you and i'll see you soon